it is June 12 2023 and you're watching
the code report if you try to go on to
the subreddit to look at adorable
pictures of puppies and bunnies you'll
notice that that subreddit has gone
private forcing 34 million people to
confront the harsh reality of our
existence as of today nearly 7 000
different subreddits have gone private
and that means tens of millions of users
won't be able to generate ad revenue for
Reddit Inc and that's not good for a
company that desperately wants to go
public before it becomes obsolete Reddit
has an incredible business model where
people willingly create content for free
that it can then monetize with
advertisements but it recently pissed
off a lot of its mods and power users by
jacking up the price of its API back in
April they announced that API pricing
was changing from totally free to 24
cents per 1000 API calls going into
effect on July 1st that's pretty steep
because serving 8000 get requests should
cost them a fraction of a penny now I
understand Reddit has to put food on its
family but they're not doing this to
make money they make their money from
advertisements and it's a problem when
you have apps like Apollo that provide a
much better user experience than the
official Reddit app and the best way to
get rid of third-party apps is to Simply
cut off the water supply or in this case
make the water supply extremely
expensive the Apollo app makes 7 billion
requests per month which means the API
would cost them 20 million dollars per
year and they ain't got that kind of
money bro which means they're officially
going out of business June 30th they
learned this trick from Elon Musk who
recently jacked up the price of the
Twitter API which used to be an awesome
free API as well a change that killed
off a bunch of third-party apps but a
platform killing off third-party
businesses is nothing new Apple can boot
you from the App Store anytime it wants
Google can updated search algorithm so
nobody ever finds your website Instagram
can turn you into a famous influencer
then erase you the moment you post
something that doesn't align with the
regime YouTube has complete control over
my fate and could easily end everything
I've worked for with the click of a
button the bottom line is that when you
build a software product any third-party
apis or platforms that you rely on have
you by the balls Reddit knows this and
they're starting to twist hard to get
rid of apps like Apollo reddit is fun
sync and red planet which in my opinion
seems like a move to eliminate
competition on mobile however the Reddit
CEO blames large language models like
chatgpt for using Reddit extent
offensively as training data but I have
a hard time buying that because Reddit
is tied to most of these AI companies
through the same VCS via people like Sam
Altman Mark Andreessen and Peter Thiel
coincidentally they all became investors
in 2014 when you're after the death of
Aaron Schwartz a dude who once said
information is power but like all power
there are those who want to keep it for
themselves what's crazy about a website
like Reddit is that you have millions of
people providing high quality content
and moderating it entirely for free
people do that because the content in
many cases is more valuable than money
like just today I was trying to visit a
subreddit for a highly specialized
medical condition that I have but it
looks like Reddit is currently also
under a DDOS attack right now which
means I might need to go see a real
doctor all Reddit has to do is knock
things up and provide a minimal platform
that keeps the gravy train running what
you really don't want is the users of
Reddit to find out that the content they
create on the internet actually has
value because then they might want to
take that content to their own platforms
where it would be far more difficult for
vulture capitalists to Feast upon now to
finish things up I need to apologize for
the lack of memes in this video
unfortunately programming humor on
Reddit has joined the protest and that
means I won't be able to steal any memes
from them for the next 48 hours this has
been the code report thanks for watching
and I will see you in the next one